analyse avec vous monsieur recall de
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur fillon
quel est l'intérêt de tik tok pour les
américains vous venez présenter des
chiffres qui sont impressionnants
sentence l'intérêt de tictacs pour les
américains c'est por un réseau social de
vidéos pour les jeunes mais c'est
surtout l'algorithme nos clients
marièrent de tik tok qui est un
algorithme qui pour la première fois
elle utilise l'intelligence artificielle
de façon absolument incroyable je suis
allé sur un mode technique ça s'appelle
le diplôme ning et l'apprentissage
profond nuire en d'autres mots en
d'autres mots ce que tik tok réussi à
faire ce que les autres réseaux sociaux
ont plus de mal à faire c'est de pousser
la bonne information au bon moment à la
bonne personne
puis c'est ça qui donne énormément
valeur à ce réseau social c'est
l'algorithme clients en arrière et donc
cet algorithme donne de la valeur et
apporte des inquiétudes dans la maison
blanche
oui en fait l'algorithme n'apporte pas
des inquiétudes mais c'est la quantité
de données que les tic toc récupère qui
apportent des inquiétudes et le
traitement de cette donnée à travers
l'algorithme fait que on a une
connaissance extrêmement précises dans
un temps extrêmement précis de
l'individu de ce qu'il fait ce qu'il
aime c'est ça qui inquiète
puis c'est la même chose pour wii chat
la quantité de données hui chat s'il est
un peu plus gros encore que le tictoc
avec 1.2 milliard d'utilisateurs à
travers le monde alors que tic toc c'est
à peu près un milliard d'utilisateurs
c'est ça qui inquiète un capi on est en
train d'observer un transfert de
l'économie traditionnelle vers
l'économie numérique et la bataille se
joue sur l'économie numérique et donc
sur la donnée et son exploitation
et est ce que on a raison de dire qu'un
retour
tik tok quitte une entreprise plutôt
socket on ne les a pas on ne peut pas
par exemple que deux sources n'est pas
dévoilé ce qu'on a raison de dire c'est
que pékin est très protectionniste par
rapport à ça ils ont un registre des
applications qui ont le droit de
s'exporter de vendre à l'étranger à des
intérêts étrangers
ce registre là
n'avait pas été mis à jour depuis 2008
et comme par hasard dans les derniers
jours il vient d'être mis à jour
ils ont ajouté tictoc un cette liste-là
donc ce que ça veut dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ces tic toc souhaiterait
vendre à des intérêts américains en tout
ou en partie
il faut qu'ils aillent chercher ce qu'on
appelle une licence une autorisation de
vendre sa technologie à des intérêts
étrangers
et là on comprend que pékin va mettre
son veto par rapport à ça et c'est pour
ça qu'ils ont ajouté dans cette liste
dans ce registre il a donc est-ce qu'on
est dans une réelle dans est ce qu on
est dans quelque chose ou on se pose de
véritables questions sur l'international
et sur la sécurité nationale où on est
dans la campagne présidentielle
américaine
excellente question je pense qu'on est
dans les deux au niveau de la sécurité
on comprend que dès qu'on parle de
données dès qu'on parle d'exploitation
de la donne et il ya des risques
associés à ça est-ce que tik tok a une
certaine volonté autour de ça j'en ai
aucune idée je me prononcerai pas là
dessus
est ce qu'il ya un risque parce que tik
tok détient de la donner oui c'est clair
qui on l'a vu il ya quelques années avec
le scandale cambridge analytica et
facebook
la manipulation justement des données
pour l'heure fait la manipulation par
rapport aux élections de l'intérêt des
gens on l'a vu il ça pourrait se répéter
à plus grande échelle avec dr donald
trump ou l'administration de washington
a raison de craindre ça maintenant c'est
plus une bataille économique aussi qui
est en arrière de ça parce que pékin en
mettant la main sur un algorithme aussi
puissant prendre certaines longueurs
d'avancé conomique m'en parle ans sur
ses rivales et donc qu'est ce que
pourrait changer l'arrivée donc d'oracle
de wade qui viendrait à obtenir des
parts de techtoc aux etats unis
l'actualité
là dessus je vous dirais que varie de
d'heure en heure quasiment sinon de
minute en minute
effectivement que le disait votre
collègue microsoft a été écartée mais
microsoft sans vouloir dire que ils
veulent revenir dans le portrait wal
mart s'est rapproché de oracle pour
pour former un conglomérat pour racheter
une partie de tik tok et là ils sont en
train de parler de créer tik tok globale
qui serait effectivement cotée en bourse
et l'association world mc avec d'oracle
détiendrait 60% des parts de tik tok le
bal et titre global gérerait les
activités de piques toque noire
américaine néo zélandaises et
australiennes
et ça ça viendrait régler le problème de
la maison blanche leur inquiétude
en partie oui oui de point de vue
politique
oui du point de vue économique
probablement pas non effectivement si
vous avez bien fait la distinction
stéphane recall merci je vous en prie
merci à vous